- Hello, everyone, I'm Maurice Samuels,
the Director of the Yale Program
for the Study of Antisemitism.
And it's my great pleasure
to welcome you today
to our Benjamin and Barbara
Zucker Lecture Series.
I'm pretty sure this is our first lecture
on the topic of Antisemitism
in South America.
The plan for today will be
that I will introduce the speaker.
He'll talk for about 40 minutes,
and then we'll open it up to questions
from the audience.
Please submit your questions at any time
during the lecture, using the Q&A function
at the bottom of your
screen and I will ask them.
The chat function is
disabled, so don't use that.
Today's speaker, Emmanuel Kahan,
holds a PhD in History and Memory Studies
from the National University
of La Plata, Buenos Aires.
And he's a Researcher
at the National Council for Scientific
and Technological Research,
CONICET, in Argentina.
He's also a professor in
the history department
at the National University of La Plata,
and teaches post graduate courses
in different higher education institutions
throughout Argentina.
He's the academic coordinator
of the Jewish Studies Program
at the Institute for Economic
and Social Development
in Buenos Aires,
as well as the education
program for teachers
on the Holocaust and other
20th Century Genocides
within the National Plan
for Teachers' Education
in Argentina.
He's also an affiliated researcher
at the Center for
Advanced Genocide Research
at the Shoah Foundation at USC.
He's the author of
several books in Spanish
on topics ranging from
the Jewish experience
during Argentina's military dictatorship
to the Israel-Palestine
conflict in Argentina,
as well as one book in English,
Memories that Lie a Little
published by Brill in 2018.
In 2013, he received
the American Jewish Studies Association's
Best Dissertation Award.
And in 2015, he was awarded
the Scientific Work Prize
by the National University of La Plata.
The title of his talk today,
is Antisemitism in Argentina,
Historical Experience, Public Debate
and Changing Meanings.
Please join me in welcoming Emmanuel.
Thank you.
- Thank you, Maurice Samuels.
Thank you, everybody for being here
and coming for listen to me.
You know I am from Argentina.
English is not my language,
so I apologize for some
mistakes I'm going to make,
I'm going to do.
I'm going to share my screen,
I have some slides to present.
So, please, I think that now
we are seeing the presentation.
Well, some years ago in the
framework of a conference
on Latin American Jewish studies
I witnessed a series of debates
about how to approach the
Jewish experience in our region.
In one of the exchange,
a researcher working from abroad
on the experience of
Jewish life in Argentina
(indistinct) quote,
"Whoever reviews the bibliography
on the history of
Argentine Jewish community
could conclude that the
life of Jews in the country,
since they wake up until
they go back to sleep,
is an ordeal.
Antisemitism is a widespread practice
that threatens their existence.
However, those of us
who know the development
of institutional life
as well as unaffiliated Jews,
we know that is not the case."
End of quote.
With a bit of grace,
this statement challenged
one of the perspective
that had been central
to the development on de-semitization
of fields of Jewish studies itself.
Research on antisemitism in my country
had revealed a concrete
and significant experience
of the Jewish life in Argentina,
but in turn, they had
cemented a distorted image
about integration of Jewish
into political, social,
economic, and cultural life in my country.
A contemporary look at
antisemitism in my country
could not fail to notice
at least three dimensions.
In the first place,
it's conditioned as a
modern historical experience
that even when it is a global phenomenon
has situated imprints.
Second, the reception use
and circulations of
antisemitism in Argentina
has particular characteristics.
A long history that mobilize
a wide group of factors
and that materializes
in a series of events
of criminal scopes.
The Tragic Week in 1919,
the closure of Jewish
schools during the '30s,
the attacks, prosecutions, and murders
promote by right wing Catholic
nationalities organizations
in the '50s and '60s,
the special treatment
of the Jewish detains
during the last dictatorship,
and finally, the terrorist attack
against the Israel,
Israelite Mutual Association
of Argentina, AMIA in 1994.
Third, the formation as a
consequence of the foregoing
of a wide and diverse
series of organizations
that devote themselves at each time
to denouncing anti-Semitic
speech and practices.
The cause of this
organizations can be rebelling.
At times, strategies for
denouncing antisemitism
were one of the engines of recognition
in the public space
of the uniqueness of the Jewish
experience in the country.
But at the same time,
they were able to hold
a speech confronting
the victims of the
persecutions against them.
This presentation aim to programatize
these last two dimensions
through a series of racist preference
based on the existing bibliographic review
and the survey of document
resulting from my research
on the Buenos Aires Police
Intelligence reports
and the consultation of
collections on the experience
of life Jewish
during the last military dictatorship.
The work of Daniel Ivovich
investigates the origin of
an anti-Semitic narrative
since the end of 19th century
among actors ascribed to
Argentine Catholic Nationalism.
This study let us know
the effects that these
early representations
had on the construction of an enemy
within the nationalist discourse
that had its heyday between 1932 and 1943.
The appearance of these ideas
and proposals around the Jewish question
combined process of origin
and consolidation of a
nationalist discourse
of a restrictive and an totalitarian type
in opposition to the liberal
and iterating discourse
that the ruling classes, the elites,
had in the last third of the 19th century.
This nationalist discourse
was have strong links
with the Catholic church
and with sectors of the
Argentine Armed Forces
that would link the idea of nationality
to the Catholic religion.
Catholic, sorry.
The reception of the
Dreyfus affair, sorry,
at the end of 19th century
was a starting point
around the dissemination
of conspiracy theories
about Jewish by Argentine (indistinct).
It will be on the characterization
of the need of the world Jewish conspiracy
that the common denominator of
Argentine restricting
nationalists was consecrated.
This theory made it possible to articulate
in the same speech
the figure of particular enemy,
the Jews, the attacks
on liberal democracy,
and the denunciation of communist danger
as well as of English imperialism.
Although the effects of this
speech around mass mobilization
proved limited quote,
"Their recurring use and the political
and literary works that they inspired,
their use in the political speeches
and as an electoral weapon,
the fact that they have
circulated in the Forces Armies
and above all, the violent
practices that it inspired
show that its influenced is
far from being marginal."
End of quote.
These narratives combine
a series of practices
that prove ominous for
Jewish in Argentina.
The Tragic Week in 1919
considered the first
program in South America
left uncertain toll of victims
and the consecration of
the figure of the Russian,
the Jews, as a political agitator.
The massacre against the Jews
in Balvanera neighborhood
took place in the
context of the repression
of the Barcelona factory strike.
The repression on the Jewish
quarter of Buenos Aires
was justify by deeply root
belief amongst the elites
and petit bourgeois about
the Jewish character
of the revolution that
were taking place in Europe
and from now on
the Incipient Union of
Soviet Socialistic Republics.
Antisemitism will constitute since then,
and at least until '80s and '90s
one of the ideological supports
of conservative nationalist
and Catholic sectors in my country.
However, not all
nationalists, conservatives
and Catholics support antisemitism,
but as the others who
have dedicate themselves
to the study of right-wing organizations
formed narratives of hatred towards Jews
were found wide expressed
within this universe of
programmatic perspectives.
It's weight among the elites
and the state officials
in various governments
was marking the pools of
a series of provisions
tending to restrict the activities
of the various Jewish organization,
as well as to homogenize the population
in relation to Catholic,
Apostolic, and Roman worship.
In this sense, the closure
of the Jewish working class
schools during the '30s
or the introduction of
the compulsory teaching
of Catholic religion with the
military government in 1943
may be illustrative of
how this imprint operated.
At this point, it's necessary to replace
one of the classic debates,
both in the field of
political representations
as well as among historians.
The allegedly Anti-Semitic
character of Peronism.
It is a controversy that
as the words of Andrés Bisso point out,
was contemporary to the
emergence of the movement
led by Juan Domingo Peron.
His trajectory linked
to nationalist sectors
that declared themselves neutral
during the development
of the Second World War
assisted the figure of General
Peron with European Fascism.
Since then a recurring
narrative has been structured
that intends to represent Peronism
as a kind of Creole Nazism.
However, the works of Rannan Rein
have tried to show that the
expansion of citizenship erased
is (indistinct) by the Peronist Regime
also had positive impact on the Jewish
who inevitably inhabited the country.
The works show that the
government led by Peron
did not promote any
measures against the Jews,
and it was even very attentive
to the demands made by the
community leaders in favor of,
for example, facilitating the
entry of Holocaust survivors
or regularizing their citizenship status,
recognizing the state of Israel
or censoring anti-Sematic
statement published
by nationalist leaders.
However, and even for
the spiritual evidence
present by Reins' works
allowed to corroborate his hypothesis.
The perspective presented among others,
by Juan Lewis (indistinct)
work on the Peronist right
cannot be neglected .
That the (indistinct)
character of Peronism
and it's raw social, programmatic,
ideological base sheltered
various sectors of Catholic
and right wing nationalist
that were deeply Anti-Semitic.
The period after Peronist
will register an increase
of escalation of
anti-Semitic speech traits
and practices.
Leonardo Senkman produced
one of the most prominent
pioneering and systematic
volumes on antisemitism
during this period.
Highlighting some of the central features
during the '90s...
During the '60s and '70s.
First, a continuing
narrative could be identified
upholding the geological
produce of previous decades.
The Jews were both the
promoters of social revolution
and financial stipulation.
But to which was added the
accusation Double Loyalty.
After the creation of the
State of Israel in 1948,
the nationalist organization
questioned identification,
solidarity, and financing campaigns
that various Jewish organizations
and prominent personalities developed
to support the new state.
Organizations such as (foreign language)
and (foreign language)
were the spearhead of a series
of campaigns that produced
widespread fear among Jewish organizations
and political activists.
Different attack against
in Edgardo Trilnik in 1960,
Graciela Sirota in 1962,
and the murder of Raul Alterman in 1964
among the most prominent are illustrative
not only of the Anti-Semitic
escalation of those years,
but also
of the process of radicalization
of political violence
that would characterize
subsequent years in Argentina.
This context must take into account
the reception of the Arab Israeli conflict
that mobilized a broader set of factors
and would give new and changing arguments
to the discourse against
Jews during the period.
During this first half of the '60s
the accusation of Double Loyalty
would have the greatest impact.
After the Six-Day War in 1967,
the criticisms would be placed
on the imperialist character
of Israel in the Middle East.
This dimension, however, is complex.
Not all the actors and
organizations that denounced
the Israeli territorial
expansion in the war context
can be described as Anti-Semitic,
but many others took
advantage of the climate
of rejection of the world to
legitimize in this public space
their positioned against the Jews.
In turn, returning to Senkman work,
one of the most outstanding
aspect of his analysis
is that he indicates
that the spiral of
anti-Semitic violence did not
necessarily respond to the
characteristic of the political
and government regimes of the period.
What does mean?
That although there has
been a tendency to think
that dictatorships were fertile ground
for the emergence of the
anti-Semitic narratives
and practice,
the detailed study of the
proliferation of threats
and attacks shows
that their increase was
during the terms of democratic governments
from 1958 to 1966,
and from 1973 to 1976.
In particular,
this last period was very
profuse in public demonstration
of rejection of the Jews.
Dispute within the ruling party
during the third Peronist period promote
a series of narratives questioning
the representation of Jewish
and their influences in
the search of government,
the business war, the cultural
and intellectual field,
and political militancy.
Following the death of
Juan Domingo Peron in 1974,
for example, his minister
of social welfare,
Jose Lo Paraja,
deployed a public and virulent campaign
against the minister of
finances, Jose (indistinct),
which was largely based
on his status as a Jew.
The presence of Jose (indistinct)
in the ministry of economy
during the administration
of Canberra and Peron
had been the cause of accusations
by the right wing
nationalists organizations
about the Jewish infiltration in power and
in Peronism.
In the same context,
two episodes relate to the
conflict in the Middle East
took place with...
During the Six-Day War.
Once again,
precipitated the question
of Israel and Zionists
in the public debate.
The Yom Kippur War in 1973
and the declaration of the
United Nation organizations
quoting Zionists as a
kind of racist in 1975.
The reception of both events
serve antagonist sectors
of the local political
(indistinct) on the right
and on the left to challenge
those who identified themselves
as Jews incorporating into the rhetoric
of the whole Jewish plot,
the accusation about that
colonial dimension of his Israel
in the context of the Cold War.
In this sense
the period characterized
by the radicalization
of political violence
as its correlate in the produce against
the Jews of many of the
political organizations
they attacked in those years.
The military dictatorship
inaugurated on March 24th, 1976
was characterized unlike the
other dictatorial regimes
that took place in Argentina
during the 20 century
by widely spread repressive policy
whose balance was 30,000
disappeared people,
500 (indistinct) children
and a significant number of
exiles and political prisoners.
The Never Again report prepared by the
National Commission on the
Disappearance of Person
(indistinct) and the
report (foreign language)
promote by the democratic
government of Raul Alfonsín
established that the
greatest number of victims
had concentrated on
certain strata of society.
Young people, workers,
professionals, leaders, politicians,
and trade unions.
And that among the universe of affect,
there was in addition
a special treatment on the part
of the perpetrators towards
the individuals who
were identified as Jews.
This representation of Jew
as a special victim of the
last military dictatorship
was forged early
and contemporaneously with the
authoritarian regime in 1976.
On September 28th, 1976,
Bart Levinson,
representative of the
Anti-Defamation League of the
(indistinct) from Latin America
present his testimony
before a commission of
the chamber of deputies
of the United States of America
on human rights in Argentina.
During his statement,
he point out the large
number of massive publication
that circulate in
Argentina and also allowed
to the fact that several
deaths in terrorist attacks
and of people who have disappeared
were the Jewish descent.
Levinson's pronouncement
started controversy
around a who had legitimacy
to denounce what was happening
and to what extent antisemitism
was a component of the policies
that the dictator regime carried out
in their so-called fight
against subversion.
The first voice that
would be raised against
the representative of the
Anti Defamation League
would be that of a journalist
who would later recognize himself
as a victim of repression,
Jacobo Timerman
However,
(indistinct) director of L'Opinion
send a letter to North
American Senator Donald Fraser
on October 1, 1967...
'66...
76,
in his capacity as chairman
of the subcommittee
that deals with the issue of
human rights in my country,
holding a different view of
the declaration of Levinson.
Quote,
"My newspaper, L'Opinion
have dealt with this problem,
human rights at all times.
Trying to do so objectively
without partiality
concerned about the human rights
of all the countries inhabitants.
In the same spirit,
I feel obligated to point out to you
the danger of hearing partial testimonies,
which I believe is happening
in that subcommittee.
L'Opinion has condemned all violence
and on several occasions has stressed
that condemning only one of the extremes,
be it terrorists from the
left or from the right,
means being an accomplice
of the other extreme.
This leads me, dear Mr. Fraser,
to ask you to be invite to testify before
that subcommission in the conviction
that my testimony will serve
to understand the human rights
of the entire Argentina
population without exclusions,
and to prevent an unnecessary
deterioration of relations
between our two countries."
End of quote.
Timerman request would be paradoxical.
He would classify years
later as collaborators
due to have the same attitude
or refuse to consider the
nature of their arrest
as a part of a anti-Semitic campaign
by the military dictatorship.
However,
the controversy as a result
of Levinson's statement shows
that the Jewish question
was a sensitive vector of
international complaints
about human rights
violations in our country.
The analysis of documents found
allow us to identify two
distinctive forms of manifestations
of anti-Semitism in the
(indistinct) period.
One of a public nature and
the other of clandestine.
While the first was characterized
by the commercial dissemination
of liberal against Jews,
threats and attack against
community institutions,
and even the official attempt to impound
the compulsory teaching
of the Catholic religion
in public education.
The second materialized more diffuse.
The anti-Semitism on the clandestine order
refers to the ways in which
the treatment of the Jews
was administrated in the
clandestine detention centers
and the various penitentiary units
where the political
parishioners were houses...
Housed under the exposition of
the national executive power.
In this sense it could be note
that the public antisemitism
was one of their central concerns
that continue to mobilize
the authorities of the
Argentinian Jewish community
and that obtained positive response
from the dictatorial authorities.
(indistinct) we closed,
numbers we seized
and anti-Semitic books from
stores for sale to the public.
Rabbis were incorporated into
television program enclosures,
the Holocaust series
got broadcast and so on.
However,
the scope for action around anti-Semitism
of the clandestine in order proved narrow
and not very permeable for the
representative of the institutions
of the Jewish community,
The centrally...
The centrality that the issue
of a special treatment of Jew
had in the period of democratic recovery
and the debates around the identification
of the crimes of the
dictatorships with the Holocaust
can be weighed by the effect
they had on actors of national
and nationalist rights.
As the work of Jorge Saborido
and Matthias (indistinct)
show,
the first years of democracy
replenished in the public space
the anti-Semitic representations...
Representations that accused the youth
of being behind the new government led by
Raul Alfonsín
and of the persecution
of those responsible
for the crimes committed during
the military dictatorship.
Although the '80s are still
a period of little work,
the aforementioned investigations allow us
to know the continued nature
of the anti-Semitic discourse
during these years.
Although there is still no
research to confirm this,
we could suggest that (indistinct) attacks
on the embassy of Israel in 1992,
and the (foreign language) in 1994
anti-Semitism as public rhetoric
and practice of nationalist Catholic
and conservative groups,
it maintained a certain
capacity to mobilize sense
or precipitate polemics in public space.
However,
after the attacks
social sensitivity
around the representation
of the Jew in public space changed.
This consideration of the
reconfiguration of antisemitism
after the AMIA bombing
would not only be a mere
declarative question,
but the methodological premise
for those of us who investigated
the development of
Argentina and Jewish life
in recent history.
Why?
A glance at the contemporary
scene cannot fail
to notice that the integration of Jewish
in the various dimensions
that make up the public sphere
has been in some sense successful.
Unlike the debates and attacks
that took place during
much of the 20th century,
the years we are going through
show various personalities
with different degrees
of self-identification
with the Jewish occupying
central functions of the
institutional, state, cultural,
and political fields.
The same could be said in
relation to the business sphere.
For some time now,
the question about the persecution
or accusations against the Jews
has been losing weight.
In any case, controversies emerged
when the topics put Israel...
Israel or the Middle East in the center.
This shift in meaning
is consistent with the impact
that the denunciation of anti-Semitism
has on the public agenda.
Does this mean that there is
not antisemitism in my country?
No, not at all,
but it's evident
that there is a broad acceptance
of an integration of
individuals of Jewish origin
in various (indistinct)
national (indistinct)
that at times, cast doubt
on the effectiveness of
their campaigns to denounce
the persecution and
hatred of Jewish developed
by local community institutions
and international organizations.
Anti-Semitic expressions that
have occurred in the country
since the beginning of the 20th century
are more like (indistinct)
versions of the interventions
and the impact that that those same...
That those same narratives
had during much of the 20th century.
It seems that antisemitism
is less (indistinct)
to the existence of Jewish
life in the country.
This could be happening for example,
in some European countries
where the situation is worrying,
then the resources for intervention
and legitimization in the public space.
National and in the
network of transnational
relations of institutions or organizations
that have representational
aspirations of the Jewish.
An analysis of the positions
of the representative entities
of Jewish in Argentina
could be illustrative of
how they seek to preserve
or to reproduce identity mechanists
that tend to unite a group,
even against the very big
themes of antisemitists
that they proposed to confront,
In 1919, for example,
during the Tragic Week,
Rabbi Alfon,
from the Israelite Congregation
of Argentine Republic,
warned President (indistinct)
that Marxist Jews were
elements outside the community.
We could point out the same in relation
to the military dictatorship
and the confrontation established by the
Organization of Relative or Jewish
Victims of State Terrorists
or more tragically,
the distance, resistance, and opacity
of the community leadership to deal
with the relatives
of the victims of the AMIA bombing.
A study of the narratives, practices,
and interventions of
institutions dedicated
to denouncing anti-Semitism
should not necessarily conclude...
Sorry.
Conclude that they seek
to defend, protect,
or represent Jews affect by
anti-Semitism in Argentina.
Thanks.
- Thank you so much for that
really interesting talk.
And I think that we'll have
an interesting discussion now.
So I ask everyone to
please submit questions
using the Q&A function,
and I will get us started.
I was wondering if you could
start by giving us a sense of
the ethnic makeup of Argentina.
So how many Jews are there?
What percentage of the
population is Jewish
and what are the other
ethnic groups in Argentina?
- Okay. Maurice.
Well, that's interesting point
because Argentina has the most bigger,
the strong Jewish
community in Latin America.
It's a biggest in a demographic sense,
but at the same time in
a symbolic sense too.
Why?
Because, well, we have
many Jewish in my country,
but most of them,
they are living in the most
important cities of Argentina.
Buenos Aires, Córdoba,
Mendoza, Rosario, La Plata.
And so they came to the country
during the big immigration
process in the 19th century,
and they integrated, I said,
during all the 20th century
and introduce then and
the right organizations
to the debates about the Jewish question
around all the century.
So it's an important discussion,
it's an important community,
but at the same time, it's bigger,
but in proportion it's not really big.
I mean, it's about now to 2000, yes.
200,000, maybe 250,000 Jews.
Maybe in the '60s there are more,
but I mean, it's less than
one percent of the population,
but at the same time,
they have a really,
I mean, they are well-known
as a great community in my country.
- And how...
Can you compare the anti-Semitism
to prejudice against other
immigrant communities in Argentina?
So was there also anti-Italian sentiment
in the 20th century or
because they were Catholic
was there less animosity?
- No, that's interesting too,
because if you saw what happened
during the first part of the 20 century,
I mean, the first 30 years
this discrimination was
put on Jewish, obviously,
but at the same time in
Italians, or some part
or some kind of in Spain people
who get into to my country.
Why?
Because, well, there are Catholic too,
but they have different languages
or they use different traditions.
So, when we saw what happened
in the scholarly system,
for example, you are
going to found not me,
but people that studied the situation.
Still, they found that the discrimination,
it's around all the
immigration during that period.
But at the same time,
these kinds of immigration,
the Italian, the Spanish immigration
they integrate more easily,
easily, more quickly.
I don't know is the word,
but the Jewish question,
the Jewish debate,
the politics around the Jewish
continued around all
the all the 20 century.
But now I think it's
because it's a new world,
what happened in the
beginning of the 20 century,
but I want to say what happen now,
because the discrimination now,
it's not only...
They doesn't have the Jewish
in the center of the debate.
They have what's happening
with other populations
that came from countries
that are near Argentina.
Bolivia, Peru, Paraguay maybe.
So the discriminations continued,
but the people that are discriminated
are others than the Jews.
- Okay.
And we're getting a lot of
questions from the audience,
but I have one more question of my own-
- Yes, sure.
- And then I'll come to those.
So can you characterize the...
Well, the response of the
Jewish community in Argentina
to antisemitism and also
the nature of the community?
Would you say that it's more insular
compared to the United States?
Like the rates of intermarriage,
for instance, are they
similar to the United States?
Do you know or?
- I remember that...
Maybe the most important
organizations of the Jewish
community in my country
had the strong policies
around the anti-Semitism
and historical. No?
The beginning of the (indistinct),
the political representation
of the community
in my country,
it's in relation with the
denounce of Nazi-facism
during the '30s in the country.
But at the same time they have this,
I mean, these arms to fight
against the antisemitism
but at the same time,
they have another policies in relation
with the continuity of the
Judaism in the country.
So I remember when I was young,
a lot of debates about
this kind of marriage,
and what's happening with Judains,
and all the debates about
what the Jews have to do.
If they have to live here or go to Israel.
I mean, these are part of the
the Jewish community divide.
But as Rannan Rains said...
Told or another researcher has said,
"Not all the Jewish in my country
are integrate to the Jewish institutions."
I mean, maybe that's a more...
It's more similar than what happen in US.
- Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Great.
Okay. So question from the audience,
can you compare the rate of
antisemitism today in Argentina
to antisemitism in other
Latin American countries?
Is there more anti-Semitism would you...
I mean, there are definitely
more Jews in Argentina.
- Yeah.
- But would you say there's
also more antisemitism
in Argentina compared to other places?
- Other places in Latin America?
- Latin America, yeah.
- Yeah.
Well, I really didn't know what happened
in all the countries of Latin America.
You know, Latin America,
it's very, very particular.
It's very big, and it's very...
They have many countries,
different countries too,
but I think that they are
going to found if you look...
If you each country,
you are going to find some
special characteristics
in each one.
I mean, Argentina has, like you said,
the biggest Jewish community
and the question of anti-Semitism
and the Jewish question is...
They move some sensibility
in public space,
but if you look what happened in Chile
where the Palestinian
community is very big, yes?
They antisemitism there
maybe it's more strong.
I mean, the BDS campaigns in Argentina
really, they didn't have...
How I can to say?
They didn't have-
- They didn't take root there?
Yes, and what happened
in Chile is the opposite.
Yes?
They really...
They are biggest there.
Yeah.
And maybe some thing
similar has happened...
I don't know what's
happened now with Mexico
and Brazil, it's a different case
because, well, you know,
now the debates about the Bolsonaro regime
and the position between
Bolsonaro and Israel,
it's particular.
So the situation about
antisemitism and the Israeli,
it's very, very special.
I think that since this era,
this new century,
the question of Israel and
the Middle East conflict
is in the middle of the
debate about the antisemitism
in our countries, too.
I think that's the same in the US
and what happened in Europe too, No?
- Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
So another question about
the nature of right wing
antisemitism in Argentina
over the course of the 20th century.
This is another comparative question.
So is it that different
from right wing antisemitism
in France, say, or in other countries?
Or is it part of the same
kind of thing would you say?
- No, really. I think that
you present a good example
because Danial Ivovich told in his study,
the Creole anti-Semitism,
it's a kind of copy of
French antisemitism.
I mean, most of the biggest,
or the first books of
anti-Semitism in my country
are maybe copies of that
Marcel Dumont wrote on France
on the final of the 20...
On the 19th century.
And then you are going to
find some relations between
what happened in French
and I in Argentina too.
And I think that this kind
of nationalists right-wing
are maybe in relation, as
other researcher shows,
(indistinct) shows that
they have some networks
and that some international networks
that they introduce the ideas, books
and they support,
I think the anti-Semitists narratives
as part of of their practices.
- Mm-hm.
And, okay.
So going back to the
point you made in the talk
about anti-Semitism
under the dictatorship,
and you know, how there was a higher...
A large percentage of the
disappeared were Jews.
Can you just say...
Can you elaborate on that?
Why, was that?
Can you say more?
- Yeah.
- I felt like that was a key
point in your presentation,
and I think people are fascinated
and would love to hear more.
- Yeah.
Yes. That's a very interesting point
and it's very polemic
because it's really that
if you look what happened
with the Jewish descended...
People of Jewish origin in my country
during the dictatorship
you are going to find that many...
2000 or 1500 people of Jewish
disappeared in this period,
and the number of disappear
are 30,000, you know?
But it's like the five percent
of the disappears are Jewish,
but not the five percent of the population
of Argentina are Jews.
So-
- (indistinct)
- Yes, yes.
Yes, you have there some problems.
I think that we can found
two answer for that.
The first one, maybe it's that...
Three answers.
The first one is
we have anti-Semitism in our
country during the 20 century,
that is real, first.
The second is,
the people that disappeared in this period
are most of them, professionals, students,
political leaders
and the Jewish are
integrated in this stratus.
So the number maybe show
the successful process
of integration of the Jewish
the the national life.
- [Maurice] Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
- And third one, maybe the
most problematic answer.
Is that the people that are
detained by the policy...
By the policy forces or the
army forces during this period
are detained by her political identity,
not her ethnic or religious identity.
So you're going to find
really 1500 Jewish disappear,
or 2000 Jews disappear.
Yes, but they are not in
the clandestine centers
because they are Jew.
They are there because they
are part of the left parties
or army organizations,
the revolutionary army organizations.
So we have to understand what is happening
during all this period?
When I say all this period
it's what happened
during the '60s, the '70s
and how the Jaffe Jewish
integrate to the political life
in my country.
- [ Maurice] Mm-hmm.
Okay.
This is a kind of difficult question.
So can you expand on
the different positions
taken by the official
Argentine Jewish leadership
and some American Jewish organizations
such as the B'nai B'rith
during the dictatorship?
And do you think that those differences
between Argentine and
American Jewish organizations
persist today in relation
to current antisemitism?
- Oh. The question about
what happened today,
it's more problematic for me
because I'm a historian.
I have all my tools for understand
what happened in the past,
but really I am very
confused in the present.
The present, it's very hard.
I think that the situation
between the different responses
of the institutional
leaders in our Argentina
and in the US during the dictatorship.
It's about the different views
or the different
possibilities that they have
in each context.
I mean, I used the
quote of Jacobo Timerman
because he's a well-known journalist
that was victim of the terrorists..
Of the state terrorists in this period.
But in 1976,
they support the dictatorships
and they attack the people in the US
that they'd say that here,
the regime are...
How I can to say it?
Are fighting the human
rights in the country.
And maybe they saw that
because they are looking all the situation
during the '60s and the '70s.
And what happened in Israel or in the US,
are that institutional, like
the Anti-Defamation League,
the America-Jewish committee,
or maybe other organizations,
The Embassy of...
Yes, the Ministry of
Foreign Affairs of Israel,
tried to support,
to help people
that are suffering human
violations in my country.
I think that now...
I don't know what happen now in the US,
but now the Jewish
leaderships in my community
are involved in political...
I mean, in political
debates maybe of more...
Many of the leaders of the community
are now political parties in my country.
So they make more confused the situation
about how did use the
denounce of antisemitism
in the present.
And really that is problem, you know?
That's interesting
because if you saw what
happened with the AMIA bombing,
you have a lot of organizations of family,
of relatives, of people
who die in the AMIA bombing
that are not in relation
with the AMIA leadership.
So there you have the problem.
- [Maurice] Mm-hmm.
So to kind of follow up on the bombing,
a very interesting question that...
You know, so that bombing in 1994,
someone points out killed 85 people
and is the largest terrorist
attack in Argentina.
- Yeah.
- So does the fact that 27 years later,
we still don't know who was responsible,
does that reflect antisemitism
at some level of society?
- Oh, in a way, yes.
Sure.
As many researchers shows,
the solidarity of the
population after the bombing,
it's very strong,
but at the same time,
we have to explain what happened
with this judicial process
that they never finished
and we didn't know who were
the author of the bombing,
of the attack.
It's a kind of anti-Semitism.
Yes, really, we can say that,
but at the same time,
maybe it's expression of the ability,
I don't know if...
I mean, the opposite of strong
of the institutional
democracy in my country.
- [Maurice] Weakness. Weakness.
- Yeah?
Because we don't know what
happened with the bombing,
but we have many processes
in relation with this attack.
I mean, what happened with the
die of the persecutor Neasman
and with what happened with the...
And any process judicial
process are resolved.
So maybe these are talking about
the (indistinct) institutional
democracy with that we have.
- [Maurice] Mm-hmm.
Okay, interesting.
So a question about academia in Argentina.
- Yeah.
- So, you know, we've
observed in the United States,
there's an increasing presence of BDS
and of anti-Israel, anti-Zionist activity
on college campuses
that a lot of people are
very concerned about.
Could you tell us what it's
like on campuses in Argentina?
Is there BDS movement strong?
Do you feel...
Is there a lot of anti-Zionist
pressure right now?
- Oh, oh.
Yes. Oh, well, this is a
different situation in Argentina,
as I said, in the other question about
what happened in Chile maybe.
I mean, here you are going to have people
that support the BDS
and have an anti-Zionist
narrative or position,
but really they are not
strong in the country.
I think that we have many,
many particular characteristics
in Argentina.
One is what happened with the AMIA...
What happened with the Jewish disappearing
during the dictatorships,
they build a representation
acceptance by the social...
The population about
the Jewish as a victim
of the dictatorship.
Then you have the
bombing in Israel Embassy
and then in AMIA in 1994.
So maybe these kind of practices
and narratives on organizations,
they are not very strong
and they're marginal now,
but have places is here.
Maybe when something
happens in Middle East,
in Israel between Palestine
and other countries in...
I mean, in Lebanon or Syria, or Egypt
while the debate introduce these...
They introduce or
legitimize these positions,
but then they move on the margin again,
and nothing happens.
I mean, I know some colleagues of the US,
of the Israel that they
have some problems in Chile
for keep classes or the
same in Israel, in Mexico,
but Argentina that's not happened.
- That's interesting because, you know,
I think that there's such
a strong kind of, you know,
traditional lefty, leftist
presence in Argentina.
So that's interesting
that the anti-Zionism
isn't necessarily part
of that, yeah, event.
- Once thing more,
Argentina is the only one
country of Latin America
that is part of the International
Holocaust Alliance...
Remembrance Alliance, the IHRA.
So they have strong policies
on Holocaust remembrance
and a commemoration, and education.
So maybe you have here some
interesting points to analyze
for understand why BDS or
anti-Zionists are not...
They exist, but are not really strong.
- Interesting.
And is there compulsory
Holocaust education
in public schools in Argentina?
- Yes.
- Do they learn about the Holocaust?
Yeah.
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
We have a...
Well, we have a new law, it's not new
because it's about the
beginning of the 21 century
about they introduced the human
rights as a great, you know,
a great field in the education.
And we have some resolutions
of the National Ministry of Education
that introduced the Holocaust...
The learning of Holocaust,
the study of the Holocaust in the schools.
And we have...
We made, I make it really, I do it.
I make the books for the Holocaust
for the training teachers on Holocaust,
studies on Holocaust education.
So we have books, we made books.
We made some videos and
it's interesting too.
Last week, we have an activity with Spain,
with (foreign language) Center of Spain
because the materials
that Argentina produce
about the Holocaust and
genocides during the 20th century
are they only ones in Spanish,
and as you know,
Spanish is a language that
we speak in Latin America,
but the US now is the second community
of Spanish people in...
Spanish talking (indistinct)
in all the world.
So maybe we can use, or
we can share these books
for Spain and for all Latin America.
- That's great.
So, you know, I think
we have been witnessing,
and I think this is a
trend that's continuing,
a kind of deep population
of Jews from, excuse me,
from many countries in the world
to either the United States
and Israel, you know?
And if I'm not wrong,
I think Argentina is
maybe still the fourth
or fifth biggest Jewish
population in the world.
- Yeah.
I mean, I think maybe after
France and (indistinct).
- I think that now is the fifth.
The fifth.
- Fifth?
- Yes.
The fifth a bigger population,
Jewish population in the world.
Yes.
- Yeah. So-
- And most of them lives in Buenos Aires.
So Buenos Aires is...
It's strange because it's Argentina,
but at the same time,
it's Buenos Aires.
- (indistinct)
It's like New York, Paris.
You know?
- That's the case in France, too,
where, you know, the Jewish
population of France as a whole
is small as, you know,
like under one percent,
but in Paris, it's actually very big
and that's the capital.
- Yes.
- So the Jews are very...
So, but do you...
And this is maybe, you know,
it's hard to forecast the future,
but do you see the community
continuing in Argentina?
Or are we seeing a kind of
increase in immigration to Israel
or to the United States
among Jews in Argentina?
Or is it...
Do you think that there's (indistinct).
- Oh, it's interesting.
I mean, I have some problems
to analyze the present,
as I said, I am historian
but really,
it's more difficult to me
look what is going to happen-
- Yeah.
- In the future, no?
But it's interesting
because, as a colleague,
(indistinct) said,
a colleague of National
University of Mexico, UNAM,
it says something interesting
and Sergio Della Pergola of
(indistinct) University too,
it shows that the maybe
Jewish life in the 21 century,
it's more a process of radius forestation.
I mean, are not people that
are going just only to Israel,
maybe I believe it's more people are going
to the US not...
Jewish people in Argentina
are thinking that the US,
it's one of the options,
but at the same time,
maybe are moving all
around the world, again.
I think Jewish community,
I think that it's going
to continue, yes really.
But as the same that
happened in maybe in the US
and maybe in Mexico too,
or in Chile, or in Uruguay,
the Jewish left is changing too,
because I mean, the
process of integration,
and now maybe the
identification with Israel
and with the anti-Semitism
that's happened now in Europe,
it's making some movements
in the representations
about the self-identification
about the Jewishness.
- Okay.
So interesting.
So we're about out of time.
So I want to really thank you
on behalf of the audience
who you can't see,
but I will clap-
(clapping)
(laughing)
- For everybody here,
a kind of virtual clapping
and really say, thank you
for sharing your expertise
and knowledge with us today.
We're really, really grateful.
And thank you to everyone
in the audience for coming.
Make sure to look at the YPSA,
the Yale Program for the
Study of Antisemitism website,
sign up for our announcements,
for our email list so
you can see what we have.
We have a lot of really
interesting programming
coming up next semester.
So I look forward to
seeing you all again soon.
And thank you again so much, Emmanuel.
- Thank you.
Thank you very much.